now are you gonna kiss me or not
i sure am jasmine
kim kardashian west kisses pete davidson
you're kind considerate mega jacked and
very very rich
and gets flirty with john cena during
her saturday night live hosting debut
it's so great to be here tonight i know
i'm surprised to see me here too
what was truly a surprise of the night
was what went down at the end of kim's
aladdin sketch where she played jasmine
alongside pete davidson as aladdin
are you intimidated that i'm friends
with a ton of wealthy celebrities and
your only friend is a monkey
uh again not nice the parody of the
disney classic earned praise from
viewers with fans calling the sketch
hilarious
i'm rolling with it on their magic
carpet ride in the clouds the two came
across jasmine's sister jortny
that's my sister journey we all have j
names
and we're joined by the genie played by
bowen yang who granted aladdin his final
wish right before davidson and
kardashian west shared a kiss on the
magic carpet now are you gonna kiss me
or not
i sure am jasmine
this isn't the first time kim has
dressed up as a disney princess
back in 2016 she dressed up as princess
jasmine alongside her baby girl north
west but that's snl
whenever you're ready
wow
in front of me are some of the best guys
i've ever met in my whole life kim
kardashian was in good company during
the bachelorette style sketch the dream
guide the 40 year old reality star was
joined by chris rock blake griffin who
was once linked to her sister kendall
jenner amy schumer jesse williams chase
crawford the bachelorette's tyler
cameron and john cena
john cena
wait
what
john c
i'm really gonna need you to figure out
your wife's situation
amy schumer the only woman included in
the sketch
okay this might be against the rules but
i've really connected with one of the
producers on the show
amy s showed off some behind-the-scenes
moments of her preparing for the skit
with the rest of the dream guys
i
there's no doubt in my mind that my next
black husband is in this room
she also shared this shot to her insta
story of her rocking kim's hot pink
statement jacket which she sported at
the close of the show i love you guys so
much good night
before kim's snl debut a source told et
that quote kim is so smart and such a
professional she really wants to do the
best job possible and wow everyone and
make them laugh
kim is extremely funny and all of her
close friends and family know that which
all tracks with what kim told et in 2017
about how she approaches new endeavors
i think my smartest business decision
has been
going for it
and not being like having no fear and
just
even if they failed and even if it
hasn't turned out the way that i wanted
to i've learned so much from it so my
advice would be
go for it